Trascrizione: Katia Pagani
Revisore: Cristina Bufi-Pöcksteiner
Noi pensavamo di essere
al centro della Terra
come esseri umani,
come specie umana,
e che la Terra fosse
al centro dell'universo.
È arrivato Copernico
e ci ha spiegato che la Terra
non era più al centro dell'universo,
come avevamo pensato finora,
ma al centro c'era il sole.
Ferita narcisistica per l'essere umano,
ma allora non siamo così centrali
come pensavamo di essere.
Come ci siamo consolati?
Ci siamo consolati dicendo:
"Siamo comunque una specie diversa,
non siamo come gli animali,
non siamo come le piante,
siamo veramente differenti."
È arrivato Darwin e ci ha spiegato
che in realtà
anche noi abbiamo
un ceppo comune con alcune scimmie
e quindi, sostanzialmente,
non siamo una specie così diversa,
perché anche noi siamo animali.
Altra rivoluzione interiore,
altra ferita narcisistica,
come sentirci di nuovo speciali
anche rispetto agli animali?
Abbiamo pensato di essere molto razionali
e di essere gli unici che
riuscivano veramente a ragionare
e ad avere sotto controllo
la nostra mente.
A questo punto, è arrivato Freud
e ci ha detto che esiste l'inconscio,
ci ha dimostrato più volte,
nell'arco degli ultimi anni
del secolo scorso,
che noi prendiamo delle decisioni
che non sono razionali,
abbiamo dei comportamenti impulsivi
che non riusciamo a controllare,
e che, quindi, non siamo
così razionali come pensavamo di essere.
Come ci siamo consolati, di nuovo,
da questa perdita incredibile?
Pensando di essere
gli unici agenti nel mondo
in maniera ragionevole,
quindi gli unici che riuscivano
veramente ad agire e interloquire,
a cambiare i processi
in maniera ragionevole.
È arrivato Alan Turing.
Alan Turing ha inventato il computer,
come sappiamo,
o, perlomeno, ha gettato le basi
di questa che è l'era che stiamo vivendo,
l'era della quarta rivoluzione,
la rivoluzione dell'informatica
e dell'informazione.
Noi siamo diventati,
al pari di animali, piante
e oggetti connessi,
degli inforg,
cioè organismi che consumano
e producono informazioni.
Se, tuttavia, un extraterrestre
oggi dovesse arrivare
e cercare di leggere, di capire,
quali sono gli esseri
maggiormente agenti sulla Terra,
quindi i dominanti con cui interloquire,
e cercasse di farlo attraverso Internet,
penserebbe che sono gli oggetti connessi,
che nel 2020 saranno 80 miliardi,
mentre noi umani saremo
soltanto sette miliardi,
quindi, gli inforg
che maggiormente agiscono
attraverso Internet, nell'universo,
sono gli oggetti.
Siamo totalmente smarriti.
Siamo in una dimensione
in cui siamo spiazzati,
ci sentiamo caduti
nella tana di Bianconiglio
e dobbiamo riconsiderare
la geografia, la storia,
lo spazio e il tempo.
I millennials, ma, ancora di più,
quelli che stanno crescendo dopo,
che leggono tutto sul digitale,
che già hanno questa dimensione
geografica completamente diversa,
una percezione dello spazio
completamente diversa da noi,
quale percezione avranno del tempo?
Avranno la percezione
e l'hanno già, di un tempo presente.
Siamo nell'Iperstoria.
Quello che vedete qui
è il professor Luciano Floriti,
filosofo direttore
dell'Internet Institute di Oxford,
che è il teorico della quarta
rivoluzione della storia dell'uomo
e colui che ha creato
anche il termine "iperstoria".
Per fare un esempio
di come sta cambiando, veramente,
la nostra concezione della storia
in base ai dati,
andiamo a vedere come è stato finora.
Noi abbiamo avuto il primo periodo
della storia dell'uomo
di cui non sappiamo assolutamente nulla,
ed è la Preistoria.
Perché non sappiamo nulla?
Perché nessun dato veniva registrato,
quindi, non c'era progresso.
Non c'era linearità.
Non si poteva imparare dalle esperienze
e dagli errori delle generazioni passate,
perché non rimanevano scritte.
E non si poteva costruire
o immaginare un futuro
sulla base dei dati del passato.
In tutta la storia dell'uomo
fino all'invenzione del computer,
l'uomo ha, a un certo punto,
prodotto, invece,
12 esabyte di dati.
Da quando?
Da quando ha cominciato
a lasciare traccia,
da quando ha cominciato
con i primi geroglifici,
i primi segni dei primitivi sulle caverne,
i primi dati a cui rifarsi
ed andare a consultare,
per partire poi da quel punto
a costruire il futuro.
Dodici exabyte fino
all'invenzione del computer,
180 exabyte dall'invenzione
del computer al 2006.
Se noi consideriamo
che la storia parte da quando
abbiamo cominciato a produrre dati,
pensate che sproporzione.
12 exabyte fino
all'invenzione del computer
e con l'invenzione - wum -
aumentano a 180 fino al 2006.
Dal 2006 al 2011 -
guardo la mano perché
me li son segnati, per non sbagliare -
(Risate)
sono arrivati a 1600 exabyte.
Voi pensate, a livello di storia,
quanto la storia in qualche modo,
se dovessimo darle
una dimensione spaziale,
si è allargata,
cioè noi abbiamo infiniti dati
dal 2006 al 2011
che superano di migliaia
quelli di tutta la storia passata.
Andiamo avanti.
Siamo entrati nell'era dello zetabyte,
quindi abbiamo avuto un salto che è
quello che dicono, appunto, esponenziale,
di dati.
E noi, fino al 2015,
che è l'ultima soglia studiata
dall'istituto di Berkeley,
che ha fatto questa analisi,
abbiamo prodotto otto zetabyte di dati.
Questo cosa significa?
L'iperstoria diventa questa dimensione
in cui, quotidianamente,
vengono prodotti nel mondo,
cioè nell'infosfera,
cioè nel nuovo ambiente
e spazio geografico
di tutti gli oggetti connessi
che producono e consumano informazioni,
cioè, gli inforg.
Noi ogni giorno, nell'infosfera,
produciamo una mole di dati
che è otto volte
tutte le biblioteche americane,
per fare un esempio che hanno fatto
gli studiosi di Berkeley.
Quindi, il presente si allarga.
Il rischio qual è?
Abbiamo pensato sempre all'uomo
in termini evolutivi
da quando è incominciata la storia.
Quindi, insomma, il primo
è quello sulla fine della preistoria,
e poi, diciamo, andiamo ad evolvere
e pensavamo fosse evolutivo.
In realtà, quello che può accadere
è esattamente l'inverso,
secondo un altro filosofo.
Un filosofo che si chiama Han,
che è un filosofo sudcoreano
che vive e insegna a Berlino,
che ha teorizzato un'involuzione
che va avanti con le nuove generazioni
che, sostanzialmente,
vivono un eterno presente.
Anche noi, in qualche modo,
viviamo un eterno presente.
Per fare un esempio molto semplice,
quando noi scriviamo un testo,
quando poi lo correggiamo,
prima avevamo la brutta copia,
quando si scriveva a mano o a macchina,
poi si conservava
una copia e si riscriveva
finché non veniva una bella copia.
Adesso, ogni volta che facciamo "save"
sui cambiamenti,
quello che c'era prima viene cancellato.
Questo vi dà un minimo esempio
della cultura in cui siamo entrati,
ed è una cultura di immissione,
in cui noi processiamo questa mole di dati
che già sembrano troppi,
specialmente a noi giornalisti,
per essere, in qualche modo,
ordinati, ponderati.
E questi dati a un certo punto
diventano un eterno presente
che è il presente dell'azione.
Quindi avere sempre, come dimensione,
solo quella del presente,
e solo il tempo precisissimo
che è il tempo dell'azione,
fa in qualche modo scomparire
il tempo in cui non c'era l'azione,
il tempo dell'ozio.
Ci insegnano, però, gli antichi Greci,
che questa civiltà occidentale
è nata sull'ozio,
i grandi pensatori
erano quelli che oziavano,
e oziando, meditavano
e processavano nella loro mente i dati
e in qualche modo costruivano
le filosofie e le civiltà del futuro.
Ora il tempo che intercorre tra due azioni
è diventato un tempo vuoto.
Han dice che questo tempo
è diventato da tempo dell'ozio
a tempo libero che va riempito
con un videogame, con un acquisto,
con un qualcosa che ci faccia divertire,
che ci distragga dalla non-azione.
Quindi, questo tempo preciso,
che è il tempo dell'Iperstoria,
allarga a dismisura il presente
e diventa il tempo dell'azione.
Nel tempo dell'azione,
eternamente presente,
passato e presente -
e questo lo vediamo semplicemente
cercando i dati nei motori di ricerca -
convivono al punto tale
che nel futuro probabilmente
le persone non sapranno più
quando una cosa appartiene -
non la sapranno più datare,
cioè quando appartiene al passato
e quando appartiene al presente.
Pensate, ora, a tutto il sapere,
a tutte le biblioteche,
a tutti gli archivi,
a tutto ciò che alcuni studiosi
ancora vanno a studiare,
a ricercare e ad analizzare,
ma che la maggior parte dei giovani,
delle persone del futuro,
che già nasceranno in un'era digitale,
guarderanno più o meno
come noi guardiamo il Colosseo,
e non li apriranno,
non estrarranno dati e senso
da ciò che non è digitalizzato.
Tuttora, siccome non ci sono troppi fondi,
anche in Italia esistono parti di archivi
totalmente inesplorati,
parti di archivi totalmente ignorati.
Quindi, brani e parti di storia
raccontati e tramandati
soltanto dai vincitori.
Potrebbero essere anche fake news,
per essere sull'attualità -
che hanno costruito la storia,
ma guidati, veri, reali,
quelli di verifica
noi neanche riusciamo ad aprirli
perché costerebbe troppo
impegnare delle persone, dei ricercatori,
che si fermano lì e si mettono
a studiare tutti quei volumi
senza sapere neanche,
in parte, cosa c'è dentro.
Ci vorrebbe Archimede Pitagorico.
Archimede Pitagorico - per anni
e anni di storie di Topolino -
ha cercato di inventare
la macchina del tempo,
in cui almeno si rimetteva in ordine
quella situazione vissuta da Nicole Kidman
nel film "The Others",
ma ci sembrava fantascienza,
e invece, no.
È arrivato un altro scienziato,
un altro studioso, e anche un artista,
che ha inventato uno scanner
che si chiama "Replica".
Questo scanner si trova
al Politecnico di Losanna,
lui si chiama Frédéric Kaplan,
e ha avuto un'idea,
un sasso nel mare dell'iperstoria,
per rimettere il tempo in Internet.
Lui ha preso tutta
la biblioteca di Venezia,
tutto l'archivio di immagini
di tutti i quadri veneziani,
e li ha passati
a questo scanner velocissimo,
quindi mille anni di storia certificata,
la Biblioteca di Venezia,
gestita dalla fondazione Cini,
è quella che ha i dati più completi
di tutte le transazioni
avvenute a Venezia -
chi abitava dove, chi faceva cosa -
qualsiasi cosa, che fosse
catastale o anagrafica,
tutto segnato per mille anni.
Quindi il più completo archivio,
in questo senso, al mondo,
o, quanto meno, della società occidentale.
Mettendoli in questo scanner,
che presto sarà anche capace
di estrarre senso dai libri chiusi,
è riuscito a creare dei pattern
che servono a individuare
lo stesso elemento
in un tempo e in uno spazio diversi.
Costruire, quindi,
un immenso motore di ricerca
della storia di Venezia
che, per fare un esempio
molto semplice da comprendere,
potrebbe consentire,
oltre che, ovviamente, agli studiosi
di accedere e studiare tutti i testi -
cosa che, abbiamo detto, economicamente
non abbiamo la possibilità di fare,
o pochissimi ce l'hanno -
di creare una sorta di Google Maps,
per restare nello spazio-tempo,
Google Maps del passato.
Io mi trovo a Piazza San Marco
e posso andare a vedere
com'era la piazza, 400 anni fa,
se ho abbastanza dati,
chi abitava lì, dove adesso c'è
un negozio di abbigliamento di lusso,
quale bottega c'era
in quella che oggi è diventata
la caffetteria più nota della piazza.
Ma posso anche fare un'operazione
del genere tra le persone.
Posso fare il Tinder di Casanova:
con chi ha avuto rapporti, Casanova?
Come si è trovato con le sue fidanzate?
Con chi erano sposate le sue amanti?
I giovanissimi saranno come il pesce
che non sa cos'è l'acqua,
perché saranno già nati nell'era digitale.
Invece noi possiamo vedere
e possiamo cercare,
come ha fatto Frédéric Kaplan,
di trovare dei modelli,
dei modi e delle tecnologie
per rimettere il tempo in Internet,
per far sì che i futuri
abitanti della Terra,
i nuovi inforg, che saranno umani
e che saranno in strettissima minoranza
tra oggetti che parleranno tra loro sempre
più senza l'intermediazione dell'uomo,
possano avere l'idea
della linearità e del tempo
che ha costruito la nostra civiltà.
Grazie.
(Applausi)